and the zombies will just can endlessly
respawn and haunt us and it's exhausting
so that's the one we're playing right
now the one where the zombies can
respawn yes so I have the respawn time
set who because they respawn in the same
spot where you killed them so if you get
attacked and you kill a bunch of them
they'll be right back so you gotta get
the hell away from there also I can
tweak when you get attacked by a zombie
technically you get infected and I can
make it so that you take damage from
being infected right now that's set to
zero yeah make sure we shoot I don't
know ours reload let's go listen to a
single thing you said yeah I had you
mute all good it's all good kill zombies
minecraft it's minecraft get your wood
will it auto deploy my parachute or well
I said well no I'm skilled
that's an appropriate reaction honestly
mark the new zombies are awful it's a
smart idea to close doors because on the
doors that's right that's right that's
right I forgot about that good like to
play we were in gross third-person I see
you want to be a douche bag yeah guys I
got the 7 to 5 I'm going to camp in this
house with a claymore good I don't have
any space yeah you gotta pick up
backpack invest I have no idea how to
play this game oh my god this game is
not for tonight so weird it feels a
little better though it does I will
admit it does feel better yeah yeah Oh
close door yeah which athlete close the
[ __ ] door you [ __ ] I mean so they
can claw the door down in like two hits
but if you at least if you close it you
have an opportunity to be like hey so
what's scratching on my door hey here's
something doing certain anagen with my
door she's got scared by a light cool
yeah that happens that happens Oh
[Applause]
okay figured out we were yeah they found
us Christmas I'm gonna have to tweak
those settings a little bit more
ridiculous terrifying I was not
overstating okay so our problem there
was we spent too long looting right we
just yeah we need to move faster I guess
I got like chills when I saw that zombie
jumped from rooftop to rooftop I was
like oh we're [ __ ]
that was some like I am Legend [ __ ] were
you guys covering your map am I the
problem off my map is covered I know my
map is covered but like the problem I
think is that everyone can see where we
were jumping if we press em like they
see where we marked and stuff let's only
show the game once we land or on the
ground sounds good yeah I just assumed
people were nice enough not to stream
snipe and be [ __ ] in North in co reg
alright there's more zombies this time
guys I think we're gonna do
better no one showing screen till we're
on the ground yeah people remember it
good thank you
yeah that was a great impression of me
but but but the graduation of me but
listen to my words all right so what's
the dealio here are we ready I'm
starting it yeah let's do this 50
zombies huh
Oh many of you zombies 51 even oh boy we
I know there's no game on screen hold on
[Laughter]
[Applause]
let you check it sound it's just like
liar liar Jim Carrey the good you you
want to leave this right now and go sit
in your sadness chamber and watch
oh go watch my video instead a lot of
money on heist with India I did because
of the poor marketing he's really
operating a loss from height around like
this oh god I was one of the wrong place
literally only one thing to even go to
how did you do that even though the
games not showing I tried to pull an old
fast e on Chad's like all you'll never
know guys I fell way short I'm going
over here instead I show the game now
yeah yeah yeah I will show it in a
second because I'm not there and I don't
want to get ganged up on on my own
wait good idea we should just not show
the game on screen oh that's good I
might be able to show the game now I
feel a little crazy right now guys
okay I'm gonna show the game but nobody
attack me Nebraska City Kansas City
Missouri
there's a I have a truck I'm coming to
pick you up
okay Oh
scooty friendly I'm gonna shoot you we
just need to stay on the run no duck all
right thank you Oh their trucks about to
explode nice the works don't sit next to
Wade Oh should I cover my map is that
what I should do hang on I gotta go
cover my map
we should get as many vehicles as
possible I'm gonna get this motorcycle
room quick like the way you're the
driver how do I change seats neutral one
somebody control one and okay you got it
you got it under control
I scream I'm in the back destroy don't
shoot you in the face when I lean out I
sniffed don't boost she's conformer for
Christmas
hello I can't boost anyway apparently so
I scream in the future oh my god they're
coming
yeah keep moving I started driving
wait yeah that is some robotic thing to
believe that we would want dipp'd not
listen to your humor if you guys want to
stop for ice cream Who am I to say no
did you see a dippin dots scent I didn't
really look I thought you saw I didn't
say stop
why would you listen to him and me are
we I guess okay I guess here we are then
we're stopping for some reason tears get
things get all the things from here
everybody's is Chris oh there's a
motorcycle with a zombie on it no it's
okay we can take him all right I think
we should go I think we should get back
I think we should back to the car
there's a car on yellow mark there's a
car go go get that go get that down by
the road I'm going back to our old car
yeah I was no Mike your old car too so
we're being stalked by one solo zombie
but I think we're safe okay get to the
car and make sure there's no zombies in
it I'm fine let's cry you already got me
here okay keep going
hey Bob hi how's it going just taking
potshots but no we're nowhere near
hitting anything yeah attack us while
we're in the car if this is the back end
yes Oh
it's just really terrifying in powerful
keep going on the road okay Jesus for me
I just want to point that out all right
I have a plan I have a plan
go to yellow mark let's guess you got
how much guess you got three-quarters of
a tank
okay follow me left oh we're good
everything's fine don't worry it's fine
we're good guys we're so good don't even
worry about it
boobalicious vehicle let us know so we
can grab another one just in case no
we're good they'll bring a vehicle kill
the zombie take the car Oh Bob Bob I
don't worry about it we're fine
everything's fine Oh what are you doing
what are you doing what are you doing
[ __ ] Bob's
I'm [ __ ] evel knievel funky okay look
how look how safe we are mr. Boddy got
it
okay I'm going so slow and responsibly
you don't even know look how look how
safe and responsible this is look guys
whoopsies it's fine yeah actually you
know what I I criticized I almost never
kill myself or other people I'm either
gonna die on the bike off the bike or
from a heart attack in real life it's so
safe right now we're so safe
it's don't don't stress don't stress
about it go to the right go in there
Wade all right mmm actually that might
be a risky move to Bob he just [ __ ]
flirted off a break here and Turner turn
it around so it's like how did it go you
know I mean cool I'm saying I'm gonna go
with mark
okay Oh friends company oh yeah okay we
were chased it's okay yeah real quick
I've got a good animal see if you can
snatch up some stuff why are you making
all that sense that place bud sorry I
don't know how to play this game I'm
going to okay all that breathing Bob's
vehicle I'm okay I'm like really good at
this game guys don't even worry about it
I've heard this I've heard of this I am
NOT like you want to see some [ __ ] right
you want to see using here then watch
the here Bob here Bob Bob there here
like this it's fire always they are
coming there's more of them coming yeah
you know go back to the cars boys just
trying to figure this thing out okay
we're trying to win here we got six
minutes okay great good they're circling
us like some yes they are they really
are okay oh come with your boy we're
going to yellow mark I really wish I
hope my boost button was it shift I
don't it's literally shift unless you
REBOUND it which would be your own fault
it shift I wouldn't have why'd you
rebind it I didn't you
about it obviously oh I see a nice jump
we're gonna shoot yeah it's us don't
worry die from that they survived that
oh my bad
pop I'm at [ __ ] hell that one you
know on it regenerates it's fine
drive around wait wait wait wait that
car kill them get that car that's the
golden morado that's the that's a
special good right now I'm so good
motorcycle just focus on surviving oh
boy
it's time like the present
I'm gonna try and save you jack but all
they're gonna finish you oh god oh god
oh god oh god okay I was just driving I
was just drunk yeah you were driving
away yeah I'm not gonna lie I was a
little scared there was driving away
black alright now I wait where are you
going now we need to go to work we need
to go god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god time to go
I'm trying wait I swear to God I swear
to god wait wait wait follow me you see
the Marco come to my bar uppies hear me
okay are you doing
that's it it's
this is the it's not I mean I'm a zombie
oh god he became a zombie
[Applause]
alright nerd oh [ __ ] alright way we only
need a minute 30 that's all we need okay
this might not be the best time to tell
you if we're down to a society we can
make it
oh boy hey wow it has literally a sliver
of health and an ounce of gas but you
can take this right here go get Bob all
right I will no I'm fine I'm fine
I got it I got I got I got I'm going for
torch right now at full speed oh it's
fine don't worry about it you're very
worried about things don't stop I'll be
trying to get your back I would not stop
why would I do that
hey don't hit me I wasn't gonna what are
you talking about I can't even see it
you guys well Jesus charisma is good
you're not supposed to
okay guys I think I'm camouflage what's
up I'm in the buggy witness on the back
that's on fire that's me boy yeah
someone's riding in my passenger see
right now we have 18 seconds wait stay
alive Mike Oh explore for some ammo
my character is I hope this Amba kills
you this is behind I went to kill that
was Wade Wade left you behind
I don't know what Wade was doing he
wasn't running I was talking to me us
alive do you know how low our cars
health got there buddy boy oh my god I
can't wait lookit man we were getting
slammed we were getting Teddy Grahams we
were getting all of it I can't believe
that worked
that was unbelievable yeah believe it
they did better without check hey I
tried to save him you douche bags in
that truck with me even you that was our
plan to pull them away from you so you
could save Jack see good we were the
distraction to the most restful [ __ ]
you guys invite me on and then yeah
vehicle vehicle boost
what is that button is that shift is it
a little arrow pointing upward yo yeah
yeah that shift you're just working you
know [ __ ] f0 wave you can only go
actual speeds you boost from one hour to
like 87 kilometres an hour I pressed it
and even more to say I press shift - it
did not boost I doubt you so sincerely
not you mark just wait I doubt you so
sincerely
[Music]
you